on the mend Jeremy Renner who celebrated
his 52nd birthday in the hospital
Saturday six days after being run over
by his seven-ton snow plow being in
touch and reached out to be doing good I
believe and oh yeah all prayers are with
Him friend and former SWAT co-star Colin
Farrell opened up to us says he won best
actor at the star-studded national board
of reviews annual Awards Gallup Al Roker
was also on the mind of host Willie
Geist after Al's Health crisis kept him
off to date for two months did y'all
know how great the situation was
essentially this is a miracle you know
honestly I didn't until Friday when we
played the piece where his doctors spoke
out publicly it was a serious deal and
thank God he fought through it and he's
back with us I lost half my blood and
they they were trying to figure out
where it was he I could get emotional
talking about Al Roker maybe I will but
he's he's so much more than our role
model as a professional he's been my
role model as a dad as a husband and so
just so happy I was in good health it's
an honor and a thrill to be named best
film of the year Show Me What You're
Made Of top gun Maverick producer Jerry
Bruckheimer also talked to us after
getting top honors ahead of tomorrow's
Golden Globes to take home an award from
them what would that mean for Top Gun
for you sir be fantastic we love it we
hope it happens for your friends payback
Fanboy are you hoping that there's a
third film absolutely yeah is one in the
work who's to say I would I would
absolutely love it I think we all would
um because we were just addicted to
jeans
greetings aviators Mike's on
[Music]
thank you